delaware your patience is commendable
we knew this was going to go long but
who knew we're going to go
into maybe tomorrow morning maybe even
longer
but look we feel good about where we are
we really do i'm here to tell you
tonight
we believe we're on track to win this
[Applause]
election we knew
because of the unprecedented early vote
in the mail-in vote
that's going to take a while we're going
to have to be patient
until we uh the hard work of tallying
the votes is finished
and it ain't over until every vote is
counted every ballot is counted
we believe one of the nets has suggested
we've already won
arizona but we're confident about
arizona that's a turnaround
we also just called it from minnesota
and we're still in the game in georgia
although
that's not what we expected
[Applause]
we're feeling real good about wisconsin
and michigan
and by the way it's going to take time
to count the votes we're going to win
pennsylvania
we could know the results as early as
tomorrow morning
but it may take a little longer as i've
said all along
it's not my place or donald trump's
place to declare who's won this election
that's the decision of the american
people but i'm optimistic about this
outcome
[Music]
and folks you heard me say it before
every time i walk out of my grandpa's
house up in scranton he yelled joey
keep the faith and my grandma when she
was laughing oh no joey spread it
keep the faith guys we're gonna win this
thank you thank you thank you
[Applause]
your patience is great let's walk over
here
you